Stevan congratulations on ten great  years of mathematica having seen it from  the start having had a chance to work  with you while you were developing it  having the first version be in the  Macintosh and doing a great version on  next step together it's been a great  ride and mathematic has changed  everything it's in use in every major  university in most major corporations  and one thing we're really excited about  here at Apple is that just as Apple is  reentering the consumer market with a  vengeance with iMac you guys are going  to be coming out with some versions of  Mathematica for consumers and for K to  12 and we are super excited about  working with you to make the next 10  years of Mathematica even more  successful than the first so happy  anniversary congratulations